hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
partei ich mache heute einen leckeren
apfelkuchen ich aber schon länger jetzt
nicht gebacken und apfelkuchen ist so
ein feiner lieblingskuchen letztes jahr
habe ich euch meinen lieblings
apfelkuchen vorgestellt aber auch der
den ich heute mache ich einer meiner
lieblings kuchen
weil ich den apfelkuchen nämlich mit
etwas marzipan verfeinere und ich würde
sagen ich sage euch einmal die zutaten
und dann starten wir gleich wir brauchen
250 gramm butter dies jetzt schon zimmer
waren 200 gramm zucker sechs eier etwas
vanilleschote und eine drehzahl 350
gramm nehmen und eine packung backpulver
und es kann sein dass wir eventuell
etwas milch brauchen dies auch zimmer
warm dann gebe ich etwas von der
abgeriebene zitronenschale mit in den
teig und das ist jetzt eine bio zitrone
und dann brauchen wir noch zwei äpfel
ich habe zwei esslöffel genommen weil
die fein säuerlich sind etwas zimt
hier habe ich noch ein paar mandeln ich
habe jetzt hier oben mandelblättchen und
unten auch noch mal gestiftet
ich habe jetzt einfach gemacht weil ich
von den beiden übrig hatte das sind
ungefähr 100 gramm
und hier liegen noch 200 gramm marzipan
und später brauche ich noch etwas puder
zu kommen bevor ich jetzt den teig
vorbereitet werde ich mich schon mal um
die äpfel kümmern
ich habe jetzt hier wie gesagt die zwei
äpfel weil die schön sauer sind
aber ihr könnt da auch zum beispiel
boskop äpfel nehmen und ich werde jetzt
die schale einfach dran lassen weil ich
das so auch ganz gerne mag und nehmen
aber jetzt mit diesem apfel entkernt
das innere heraus das kann weg und wenn
ihr sowas nicht habt könnt auch einfach
den apfel vierteln und daneben das
kerngehäuse entfernen
und jetzt werde ich meinen apfel einfach
nur noch halbieren und in dünne scheiben
schneiden und die messnetz gewürfelt
werden
das mache ich jetzt einfach wieder hier
in dem alligator weil das ziemlich
schnell geht und sehr laut ist
und so hat da ganz schnell die äpfel
feingefühl punkten
und die gebe ich jetzt hier in so eine
kleine schüssel rein und geht da schon
mal meint sind pulver mit dazu das müsst
ihr natürlich nicht nehmen aber ich
finde zu essen gehabt sind auf jeden
fall immer mit dazu einfach so viel wie
ihr wollt ich nehme jetzt ungefähr 1
teelöffel und mich ist einmal durch und
damit die apple jetzt nicht braun werden
muss ich da jetzt noch ein bisschen
zitronensaft dazugeben
ich werde aber vorher die zitronenschale
etwas abreiben weil ich die in den teig
geben will und es geht einfach besser
wenn die zitrone noch im ganzen ist es
gibt hier einfach in so eine extra
schüssel rein und damit darauf achten
dass es bio zitronen sind was da eben
die schale nicht behandelt ist und ich
nehme mich da die schale mit in den teig
weil so sei einfach viel besser wird ich
finde dass die zitronenschale supergut
zu den marzipan und zu den äpfeln passt
und so könnte die schale von bio
zitronen eigentlich immer mit verwerten
als auch wenn ich die schale card nicht
braucht weil ich sie mal ab und fräser
einfach rein und dann können dass sie
irgendwo mit rein verwenden unternehme
ich hier einfach mit zitrus presse und
presst die zitronen aus das hier ist
jetzt übrigens eine von september chef
und die finde ich super weil man so mit
der ganzen kraft den kompletten
zitronensaft auspressen kann und das
ganze auch ziemlich schnell geht
kommt
und jetzt wird es einfach kurz verrührt
und jetzt kann ich das hier am rand
stehen lassen und den teig vorbereiten
und die äpfel werden jetzt auch nicht
frauen einfach weil der zitronensaft und
die zitronensäure dieses verhindert ich
mache jetzt meinen rührteig in einer
küchenmaschine aber wenn ihr keine
küchenmaschine habt geht es natürlich
auch mit einem elektrischen
handrührgerät und wichtig bei der
küchenmaschine ist aber dass er hier
diesen flachen röhrer benutzt also
keinen schneebesen den rührteig hört man
immer mit diesem flexibler und diese
röhre hier sind ganz super weil man
damit auch schön alles vom rand weg
kriegt und da einfach nichts dran hängen
bleibt
zuerst kommt jetzt die weiche butter in
die rührschüssel und dann gebe ich da
den zucker mit dazu und lass das ganze
krise spüren
die mutter muss ungefähr so 12 minuten
rühren bis schön weiß cremig ist dann
seht ihr sie nämlich so aus und jetzt
gebe ich während im rühren nach und nach
die eier mit dazu und lass es noch mal
eine minute weiter rühren
und jetzt berühre ich hier die
trockenzeit hat miteinander und wenden
hier keine vanilleschote habt könnt ihr
einfach auf vanillezucker nehmen wir
nach vorne treiben und dann schicke ich
das ganze hier rein
auch die zitronenschale
jetzt wird es nur noch ganz kurz
verrührt
sie ist sich einfach alles schön
verbunden hat
und dann könnt ihr jetzt das marzipan
nehmen und einfach in kleine stücke
reißen und mit ihnen den teig rühren das
machen wir dann aber per hand mit dem
teig schaber und wer kein makel ist
einfach weg ich finde es hat einen
schönen geschmack und ist so ein schönes
und jetzt kann ich das ganze andere
unterrühren und man könnte hier
natürlich auch das marzipan mit in den
teig rühren
aber ich wollte so ein stückchen reisen
weil dann hat man im teig im kuchen ganz
so kleine mazet stücke und das finde ich
ganz lecker so den teig gebe ich jetzt
in meine vorbereitete backform ich pack
das heute in meinem back rahmen den habe
ich jetzt auf etwa 30 x 28 cm
eingestellt ihr könnt es aber auch
einfach einem backblech backen oder in
einer großen springform ihr könnt auch
das rezept halbieren eine kleine
springform nehmen also das halbe rezept
wird so für eine 20er form reichen und
dieses große rezept so für eine 30er
form und dann gebe ich das da drauf ich
finde sich einfach so ein perfekter
blechkuchen den mal kurz vorbereitet und
dann haben ganz viele menschen was davon
und das muss auch gar nicht so glatt
sein sondern einfach ein bisschen
unregelmäßig und da geben wir jetzt noch
die kleinen apple mit drauf das wird
übrigens auch prima mit ihren gehen
das ist auch so ähnlich und dann könnte
er da einfach noch die mandel blätter
mit drauf geben
ich habe jetzt ganz vergessen meine
mandeln in der pfanne an zu rüsten das
wollte ich noch machen damit das aroma
ein bisschen intensiver wird aber das
macht nichts so schmeckt auch ganz gut
und jetzt wird der teig gebacken in
meinem vorgeheizten backofen bei
ungefähr 180 grad für etwa 25 minuten je
nachdem in welcher form er packt kann es
etwas länger oder kürzer dauern
ihr müsst einfach die stäbchen probe
machen mit dem zahnstocher und wenn der
kuchen fertig ist holen wir ihn heraus
und jetzt mache ich die stäbchen probe
einfach den zahnstocher reinstecken in
die mitte am besten
und wenn nichts mehr dran kleben bleibt
eines der tyczka hier schützen kleiner
brösel dran aber das kann jetzt auch
formal chip ankommen
ich nehme den kuchen jetzt heraus und
jetzt mache ich hier noch einen kleinen
bus drüber und zwar nehme ich mir
nochmal eine zitrone ich habe freunde
ganze zitrone aufgebraucht und habe nie
daran gedacht dass ich nochmal eine also
noch mal ein bisschen zitronensaft graz
1 esslöffel voll und puderzucker und den
sie bisher jetzt rein damit ich keine
klümpchen drin hab es dauert mit dem
arbeitsminister und dann einfach kurz
verrühren und wer ist der kuss zu fest
ist gibt er noch ein bisschen
zitronensaft rein und wenn er zu flüssig
ist einfach noch ein bisschen
puderzucker
ich brauche noch ein bisschen
zitronensaft
und nochmal bisschen butter zucker und
west gern zimt ich mag nimmt einfach nur
ein bisschen zimt was ihr auch ganz gut
passen würde wer etwas muskat ich glaube
das nämlich jetzt auch einfach nur ein
bisschen
also nehmt einfach gewürze die euch am
besten schmecken und muskatnuss wird
auch im teig ganz gut reinpassen
und diesen kurs nehme ich jetzt und ließ
ihn einfach so ein bisschen über den
kuchen drüber
und da mache ich jetzt auch nicht zu
viel weil ich jetzt nicht will dass der
kuchen zu viel nach diesem bus schmeckt
und zuschauer wird so lag der fokus auf
dem marzipan legen und auf den äpfeln
und deswegen einfach nur ganz leicht
also ich war jetzt nicht komplett ist
der kuchen abgekühlt ist sondern löst
ihn jetzt schon von meinem springt vom
rand oder torten rand und zwar habe ich
hier so ein kleines tortenring messer
das unten nicht spitz ist und es ist
jetzt ganz wichtig weil ich mir
ansonsten meine folie jetzt schneide
und jetzt kann ich das hier ansetzen und
den torten rand lösen geht dann auch
ganz schnell kann dann den ring
entfernen oder den bug rahmen und damit
ich mir jetzt hier die unterlage nicht
der schneide werde ich die einmal kurz
entfernen
und ich hab da auch schon meinen torten
rettete runter also hier dieses
fleckchen dann kann ich das hier einfach
wegziehen und wenn ihr möchte das jetzt
gar nicht gleichmäßige stücke habt nehmt
ihr hier diesen trockenen schnitten
tyler und könnte es hier drauf legen
ich hab einmal 30 und 1 x 24 stücke und
ich nehme jetzt einfach die 30 stücke
und dann kann man da einfach nur noch
entlang schneiden und hat ganz
gleichmäßige stücke dann streitet sich
auch keiner um das größte und stein
könnt ihr den kuchen auf eine platte
geben und servieren uns letztes stück
nämlich jetzt auf einem teller und zeige
ich das jetzt einfach mal uns war es ihm
richtig schöner weicher kuchen mit den
knackigen mandeln drin und den weichen
äpfeln und wenn ihr mal dran riecht
werdet ihr merken dass er richtig schön
nach marzipan und zitrone weg und so ist
das für mich der perfekte herzt kuchen
dieses rezept gibt natürlich zum
nachlesen auf sallys - blog.de
das ist mein neuer blog gibts die
rezepte alphabetisch und nach kategorien
sortiert da könnt ihr mal nachschauen
und können durch das rezept direkt
ausdrucken und einfach starten ich
verschlinge den kuchen mit meinen gästen
hier und wünsche euch noch ganz viel
spaß beim nachmachen und wir sehen uns
nächste mal wieder 50